[Music]
i
personally am very quiet before i go on
stage
i like mine space
first time uh i came across shawn
janae's work was when i was a teenager
his voice gets right inside your head
you're right there you're completely
involved completely immersed
it's almost hallucinatory
when you hit the stage everything just
happens it's like being instantly in a
movie
[Music]
when i first walk on stage i want to
look so memorable
that people don't forget you know
he wrote himself at a prison
you know it's kind of like he dreamed
his way out and i can relate to that
we dreamed our way of god's gone
he was abandoned he went to prison
he became a thief he joined the army he
deserted
he rejoined i see quite a colorful life
[Laughter]
[Music]
he had an affinity for oppressed people
so he was always on the outside of
society
be a stranger in a strange land
it's just the nature of pause here alone
normally the songs are the hardest to
write
are the the songs that mean the most to
other people
but those are the songs are the rawest
and the realest
the most truthful
you go be brave and you go right huh you
go record
[Music]
he them betrayal of rupture
never wanted to be controlled by anybody
or anything
he had such a strong belief in
individual freedom
[Music]
i think it's a beautiful thing you can't
crush the human spirit
live and let live do your thing and
you let me do my thing